Corea del Sur y Estados Unidos han
anunciado hoy que celebrarán sus
ejercicios militares de primavera
freedom shield del 13 al 23 de marzo en
un momento en el que la tensión está en
niveles históricos en la Península
coreana en freedom shield se han
incluido maniobras con tropas sobre el
terreno a gran escala según han
explicado hoy portavoces militares de
los aliados en seúl Corea del Norte que
normalmente suele considerar este tipo
de ejercicios común ensayo para invadir
su territorio ya ha prometido que daría
una respuesta sin precedentes a freedom
shield incluso llegó a decir que si
finalmente los ejercicios se celebran el
régimen podría considerar esto como una
declaración de guerra de este modo
muchos temen ahora la respuesta
norcoreana puesto que la última vez que
seúl y Washington celebraron maniobras
militares a una escala similar el pasado
noviembre
pyongyang disparó 30 misiles entre ellos
uno intercontinental en apenas tres días
ante la aparente falta de voluntad para
impulsar la distensión por ambas partes
los expertos vienen señalando el
creciente peligro de que en la Península
coreana se produzca un error de cálculo
que pueda tener consecuencias fatales